well these pants are so tight your jeans
came in just struggle sick dude
yeah they feel bad loss I think I need
to get an IV for my cheek that levees
about to break brother I think it's you
came in the jeans off the threating
smuggling some [ __ ] if you put your here
so hard you can hear my video and
wouldn't
why is your ass so swole these days yeah
I've been going to a trainer who's this
[ __ ] trail I need to see them dudes
cardi B son yeah I got that cardi bottom
dude the the problem with me is one of
the problems is the the bottom half of
my body looks different than the top
half of my body it looks like my top
half is me and the bottom half is like a
rental no it's like no top how I feel
top half soccer-mom bottom half just a
[ __ ] NFL running back wait you're a
fullback for the Steelers and big
haunches dude down here dude are you
sorry giving a lot of attention on the
streets mmm no you don't the see you
pregnant paying attention to it first of
all I don't want people seeing me for
having a big butt dude I already have a
very unique look it's the last thing I
need and also I beat down syndrome a lot
of people know that and so this is one
of the side effects though hold that
down butts
oh dude them boys cut back grown up I
hang out with Blanton had a black girl
with Down syndrome in our school named
clarinet first a second named clarinet
not clarinet clarinet yeah
yeah and people would always make us be
on the same team for everything
I bet dude she's cool Internet and
ruffles let's get at it'll ruffles
double ruffles with that [ __ ] ass you
know little ruffles yeah yeah it's weird
man you can't wash jeans you can't wash
jeans yeah one washer I gotta get my
jeans away Doug well I feel like I feel
like uh ever actually screw all you guys
have big asses dude everybody
everybody's big ass city city big ass
nation although nick mr. burns is still
growing
get those prima cheeks bro I feel that
down go to deals trainer rope and see
what we can do then do - I feel like my
skin's are big it's a bit like it's
gonna [ __ ] sneak up on like mine now
boy dude I feel like somebody's picking
my ass up I like a string and just
pulling it up into the air really got a
move dude you ever seen that hippo
you're seeing the hip on Madagascar get
out the water
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
children family big asses big and chunky
did not oh you almost had Down syndrome
and I just slipped out of his inch they
left you the good stuff boys half in and
half out if flares up dude if you see me
waiting for a school bus if I'll tell
you this if seven school buses drove by
the short ones always would stop for me
dude they'd always be like you ready you
come on you don't like no wait I said no
I'm on a big one and the lady would look
at me are you sure honey yeah yeah and
she usually asked me a times table or
ask me an addition table if I got it
right you say all right keep it on your
toes yeah good luck out there
but do you also look like [ __ ] run in
years I don't forget that Brennan looks
like every buck in big girl that works
at a snow cone say like oh you wanna
condensed milk on net ha ha that's so
disc what do you want Tigers blood
ruffles listen bro listen little rice
listen ruffles I love that you look like
a baby hippo what's this big J don't
think we forgot about your flat ass
either zero zero
janessa staples jeans do that to gather
his shirt he could be one of those
cornhole games he just let his head he
just aim for his bottle Oh play
skee-ball in here's just a central beach
up it's easy let's make some cobbler
ruffle row we got Chappell Lacy and we
got our hat in today welcome back hat
look lovely today I got a tan yeah did
you do hard I went to the beach wow it's
crazy you went to the beach in Brendan's
dress like [ __ ] gay simple Dead
grateful breath another would like this
my you wouldn't like that vibe man he
really would I can't remember if I
thought this hop or if if I read this
online somebody said Brendan looks like
the kind of guy that during
hide-and-go-seek right when the person
starts counting he runs out too and he
goes hey come find me first
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
if I was counting I would find you first
the kid
oh man I'm sweating it's hotter noon now
you're right it's hot in my pants
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]